baliser le terrain où s'est écrasé un
mirage 2000 le 9 janvier est toujours
interdite d'accès encore sur place des
militaires de l'armée de l'air
principalement de la base de luxeuil
il débutait aujourd'hui les opérations
de dépollution et de sécurisation du
site
pour le moment nous avons à l'ordre
d'une vingtaine de personnels en fait
ils sont des moyens lourds de génie pour
débuter ce travail donc ça consiste à du
bûcheronnage on va couper les arbres et
les branches qui pourrait être instables
les éliminer aussi et bien évidemment
aussi aux endroits où il ya eu un peu de
terreau zen récupérer la terre pour voir
le la l'enlever du terrain
ce travail d'ampleur pourrait durer
plusieurs semaines ces derniers jours
les militaires ont retrouvé une grande
partie des débris de l'appareil
des éléments de la boîte noire notamment
la mémoire vive de l'aéronef placés sous
scellés judiciaires ils seront analysés
durant son entraînement
l'avion volait dans de mauvaises
conditions climatiques mais on ignore
pour l'heure l'origine du crash
un appel à témoins a été lancé par la
gendarmerie de l'air chargé de l'enquète
l'accident a coûté la vie à un pilote et
à une navigatrice les familles se sont
rendus cet après-midi sur les lieux du
drame pour se recueillir